vamos a platicar un poquito acerca de lo
que pasó en el vídeo pasado ahorita
vamos a repasar estas ideas de que entre
el dinero y también vamos a platicar si
es razonable que la gente piense que
tiene el dinero que cree que tiene bueno
al inicio del vídeo y ya sabe los
granjeros tuvieron su cosecha metieron
mil piezas de oro en mi banco y de esas
mil piezas de ahí pues presten 900 tenía
que guardar un poquito en caso de que
los granjeros quisieran sacar algo y
supuse que nunca sacarían más del 10%
bueno preste esas 900 hicieron un canal
de irrigación alguien tuvo la gran idea
de construir este canal de irrigación
para que más campos se volvieran este
plan table lo que sea entonces tomaron
esas 900 piezas se lo dieron a unos
trabajadores y esos trabajadores que
obtuvieron las piezas de oro quisieron
guardarlas y las depositaron en mi banco
entonces tengo 900 piezas en mi banco
esas 900 guardé tantito y preste 810 2
810 se las preste a alguien que quería
hacer una fábrica de esa fábrica era
para hacer herramientas que
simplificarán la cosecha o que la
hiciera más rápida o más cómoda no sé lo
que sea entonces para construir esta
fábrica
esas 810 piezas se le pagaron a algunos
albañiles verdad esas 810 se las dimos a
los albañiles y los albañiles las
volvieron a depositar en mi banco bueno
ok este aquí es el lugar más seguro para
depositarlo y dije sabes que aquí me voy
a detener podríamos seguir y seguir pero
hay un límite porque fíjate que estos
números van bajando después hacemos
matemáticas de eso pero bueno entonces
recibí el dinero de los albañiles y dije
sabes que soy nuevo en esto de la banca
así que voy a guardarlo y lo voy a poner
como reserva por si las moscas y aquí se
la pregunta cuánto dinero hay en el
sistema claro lo primero es ver cómo
definimos dinero una definición es esta
que puse por acá que es m 0 y m 0 era
simplemente cuánto dinero cuánto oro hay
en el sistema es la definición más bruta
esto se refiere a cuánto oro hay no
bueno cuántos recursos hay que se puedan
usar inmediatamente para realizar alguna
transacción económica
bueno pues suponiendo ahorita que pues
ninguno de estos jugadores se quedó con
oro en sus bolsillos verdad cada nadie
se quedó con efectivo en sus carteras ni
nada si lo hubieran hecho pues lo
meteríamos a la cuenta
y tenemos estamos suponiendo que todos
lo depositan aquí en el banco de sal
entonces al hacer este cálculo obtuvimos
estos 100 de aquí estos tienen reservas
verdad más estos 90 y 90 si 90 90 y
estos 800 10 entonces cuando sumamos eso
obtenemos 1000 piezas de oro en el
sistema lo cual es bastante razonable es
muy muy razonable porque iniciamos con
1000 piezas de oro y de todo lo que
platicamos en el ejemplo pues no había
nadie que consiguiera nuevas piezas de
oro ni nadie se comió el oro ni lo
destruyó o sea no pasó nada con el oro y
entonces es muy razonable que tengamos
mil piezas entonces tiene todo el
sentido del mundo que sigan siendo mil
pero hay una pregunta que es más
interesante si vamos persona con persona
y les preguntamos cuánto dinero tienes
pues lo que nos van a decir es cuánto
tienen en su cuenta de ahorros verdad en
su cuenta del banco si me preguntaras a
mí por ejemplo yo te diría cuánto hay en
mi cuenta de cheques y pues no te
contaría cuánto hay en mi cartera porque
cualquiera secuestrarme lo que sea
entonces todo el dinero lo metí en mi
cuenta de cheques
entonces alguien me pregunta le digo
cuánto años mi cuenta de cheques y si le
preguntamos a todos verdad si le
preguntamos a todas las personas y los
sumamos vamos a obtener este el total de
las cuentas de ahorros es 810 de los
albañiles más 900 de los trabajadores
que hicieron el canal más 1000 de los
granjeros es saber en 1900 810 es si 2
mil 710 piezas de oro en total en las
cuentas de cheques como soy el único
banco eso es lo mismo que el total de
mis pasivos va eso de ahí le pusimos m1
y no te preocupes m 1 y m 0 son los
términos formales que se usan en la
economía y en el gobierno ahora de aquí
salen algunas preguntas interesantes una
es como mil piezas de oro se hicieron
dos mil 710 piezas de oro y otra
pregunta es si estas dos mil 710 piezas
de oro representan riqueza real es
riqueza real o estamos jugando a los
frijolitos y esto acá es como un esquema
piramidal así rebuscado
como se creó ya sabemos o sea la idea
era muy sencilla simplemente prestaba a
esa persona lo volvía a meter y luego yo
lo volví a prestar etcétera así se creó
pero la pregunta interesante es si
representan realmente riqueza la
respuesta es la siguiente representan
riqueza siempre y cuando estos estos
proyectos de acá fueron inversiones
reales o sea si estas 900 piezas que
usamos para hacer el canal de irrigación
este funcionan son una inversión buena o
sea si ese proyecto realmente hace al
menos 900 piezas de oro de riqueza en el
futuro o sea esencialmente si se puede
pagar la deuda a lo mejor se puede hacer
más y es un buen proyecto pero si
alcanza para pagar la deuda para pagar
estos 900 piezas de oro entonces esto es
una activo de adeveras esto es un activo
que si tengo demo similar con la fábrica
si la fábrica genera al menos 810 piezas
de oro de riqueza futura entonces bueno
a lo mejor hace más verdad no sé por qué
sea pero si genera riqueza de alguna
forma entonces este es un activo real
estás 810 piezas es un activo real
esta riqueza realmente existen estas dos
mil 710 piezas de oro bueno realmente
son entre comillas riqueza siempre y
cuando los proyectos los proyectos que
fueron financiados por los préstamos
funcionan vale eso es muy importante
entonces hay que practicar algunas cosas
no hay 2.710 piezas de oro de adeveras
en el sistema nada más hay mil piezas
físicas de oro pero si estos proyectos
son así súper buenos y son proyectos
reales así no son ni estafas ni estamos
tirando el dinero a la basura
osea suponiendo eso entonces realmente
tenemos dos mil 710 unidades de piezas
monedas de piezas
no monedas de oro esto aquí es un punto
importantísimo el oro no es riqueza por
sí mismo o sea no puedes comerte el oro
no puedes respirar el oro este no sé el
oro no te va a transportar mágicamente y
pues tampoco va a mejorar tu salud
mágicamente el oro simplemente es algo
que usamos para representar la riqueza
algunas personas creen que es riqueza
por sí misma pero es un error muy común
bueno estás 2.710 piezas de oro
lo importante es que representan riqueza
representan riqueza aunque no
representen piezas físicas de oro otra
vez es muy fácil pensar que todo todo
este desbarajuste es un juego de
frijolitos pero no lo es no lo es
siempre y cuando éstas sean inversiones
que generen riqueza observa que la
cantidad de dinero que la gente cree que
tiene que es m1 aumentó para facilitar
el crecimiento económico la producción
económica entonces siempre y cuando esta
fábrica me ayude al crecimiento
económico o sea si ayude a generar
riqueza aunque haya aumentado la
cantidad de dinero que la gente cree que
tiene pues
en realidad como aumentó más la riqueza
entonces por ejemplo si antes podíamos
comprar una manzana ahora vamos a poder
seguir comprando la y de hecho podría
ser más barata sea si estas inversiones
son muy muy buenas no sé o sea vamos a
hacer un ejemplo supongamos que antes
podíamos hacer mil manzanas al año mil
manzanas al año observa que las manzanas
son riqueza real es algo que si puedes
consumir que las comes y puedes seguir
vivo but también puedes pensarlas como
una inversión porque te los comes
trabajas pero bueno supongamos que antes
de todas estas inversiones antes del
banco en nuestra economía podía hacer
mil manzanas al año ahora supongamos que
gracias al proyecto de irrigación
podemos hacer más manzanas no sé en vez
de hacer mil manzanas mil manzanas
podemos hacer no sé digamos en el doble
podemos hacer dos mil manzanas dos mil
manzanas
ahora fíjate se cree un montón de
riqueza tomamos 900 para hacer un canal
y de repente duplicamos la cantidad de
manzanas que pudimos generar aumentamos
mil manzanas en nuestra economía antigua
eso equivale a mil piezas de oro y
entonces el proyecto se pagó verdad
estas 900 piezas las usamos para generar
no mil piezas de oro físicas pero mil
piezas en riqueza verdad mil manzanas
que eran equivalentes a mil piezas de
modo similar acá arriba supongamos que
la fabrica hace que podamos producir no
sé de tres mil tres mil al año entonces
pensemos un poquito ahora en un año dado
cuantas manzanas se están produciendo
pues antes podríamos hacer mil manzanas
verdad ahora podemos hacer tres mil
manzanas gracias a esta innovación
porque estos fueron proyectos muy buenos
que ayudaron a crecer la economía
entonces pues la gente piensa que hay
dos mil 710 unidades de oro piezas de
oro en él en la aldea pero podemos hacer
tres mil manzanas fíjate que la cantidad
de dinero creció más
que la cantidad de manzanas eso estuvo
muy bueno déjame hacer acá arriba un
diagrama antes iba a poner dinero y acá
voy a poner riqueza es muy muy
importante separar estos dos conceptos
dinero simplemente es algo que
representa riqueza no es riqueza por sí
misma y riqueza pues si es riqueza esto
tiene ciertas implicaciones filosóficas
que creo que harían a la gente más feliz
pero bueno empezamos con con mil piezas
de oro antes del banco y habíamos dicho
que podíamos producir mil manzanas
ok y ahora
después en las cuentas hay dos mil 710
monedas de oro percibidas este de aquí
es el m 1 el m 0 sigue igual el m 0 el
oro físico sigue siendo mil piezas pero
cuánta riqueza tenemos pues ahora son
tres mil manzanas tres mil manzanas en
riquezas observa la razón de oro a
manzanas de hecho mejoró y si lo piensas
tantito una manzana va a costar menos en
esta economía porque antes era una pieza
por manzana y ahora es menos que una
pieza de oro por manzana justo por
nuestra innovación por nuestros
proyectos hicimos que las manzanas
costarán menos es guau generamos riqueza
de la nada no no no recuerda que no se
creó de la nada esto fue gracias a que y
esto es muy importante porque el dinero
se puso a trabajar en proyectos que
realmente generaron riqueza valen que
hicieron que la aldea se desarrollara va
muy bien entonces esto está padrísimo
experimentamos una baja en el precio de
la manzana lo cual es algo bien
optimista en el próximo vídeo hablaremos
de notas bancarias hasta